or it already doesn't exist on a binary
there are intersex people there are
people that have genetic differences
that does fall out of XX and X Y so it's
there is already reasons for why we see
things a little bit differently whereas
with black and white is just like it
doesn't make any sense
if you look on a DNA level those classes
of people are classed as abnormal it's
an anomalies not natural it's not you
know
that's the point do you know what
genetic differences always used to lead
to in the past it was called Evolution
yes and there are genetic differences
that have led to Devolution
obviously but the point is by natural
selection there are people that have
existed that do not fit into the normal
binary system and things like that have
been like natural selection thick scale
things like that